ma présence est notre capitaine c'est un
certainement le sport le plus populaire
près de deux cent mille jeunes au québec
joue au soccer dans les ligues
organisées
alors c'est sans compter tous les autres
jeunes qui jouent pour le plaisir un peu
partout sur le terrain vous les voyez
comme nous quand on se promène dans la
très grande région de montréal
un peu partout au québec où si la coupe
du monde on disait c'est le 12 juin
prochain au brésil que ça commence et
nous on a décidé juste une bouteille de
d'identifier d'aller voir une dizaine d'
équipes de la grande région de montréal
pour voir comment on vibrait à la coupe
du monde
exactement et vous les voyez vous voyez
une partie de ces huit équipes bloc
participant au défi ma coupe du monde et
son je suis bien entouré des spas
garceau effet alors on a huit équipes au
total j'ai cinq équipes de garçons cinq
équipes de filles sont des jeunes
joueurs et joueuses âgés entre 13 et 17
ans alors les équipes auront deux
semaines patrice pour se faire connaître
du grand public pour parler de leur
passion pour le soccer et par les
maîtres des vidéos des photos et soudan
le biais des réseaux sociaux alors
d'ailleurs pour voir ce que les équipes
ont préparé on a une section spéciale et
je vous invite à la consulter sur le
site web de radio-canada section
spéciale qui s'intitule ma coupe du
monde maintenant pas très honoré de
venir font pas ça pour rien est une
petite compétition donc il ya un prix un
très beau prix à remporter l'équipe
gagnante va accueillir les joueurs de
l'impact de montréal sur son propre
terrain pour un entraînement le 12 juin
prochain alors ce très beau prix y aura
des membres du jury dont vous faites
partie à patrice justement qui vont
avoir la lourde tâche de décider et qui
sera le grand vainqueur et on va
dévoiler le vainqueur du défi ma coupe
du monde ne
juin prochain maintenant je disais que
j'étais est bien accompagné g zachary
qui était à côté de moi et marianne et
illzach avions va commencer avec toi tu
avais que la hesb les villes et pourquoi
tu penses que l'impact devrait venir sur
ton tel ce qu'ils savent que ça va nous
motiver on est troisième au classement
on espère que ça va nous faire monter
premier c'est sûr que c'est toujours le
fun à orly joie de l'impact devant nous
sur le terrain puis si nous qui va
prendre la relève fait que sa cause de
ce père si zachary et j'avais côté
mariale des comètes de brassards
marianne2 un droit de réplique pourquoi
l'être voudrait voir l'impact mais avant
nous on mérite de gagner parce qu'on est
une équipe qui travaille fort on a une
belle chimie on est premier dans le
classement trois équipes tout ça alors
je vous souhaite bonne chance à tout le
monde et sans plus tarder on va regarder
ensemble bref aperçu la petite vidéo un
bref aperçu à des équipes
un pot-de-vin capitaine de bleus
habitude la fierté de françois way rally
capitaine thomas commandant chez
certaines des portions on est la mode à
cette tâche
j'aime à me présenter notre capitaine
jean est devant nous
seul mickaël c'est capitaine de mon
équipe
les époux m'a de montréal nord un deux
trois fois
alors on le sent jeu scène ils sont
passionnés
d'ailleurs j'irai me promener un peu
partout au cours des deux prochaines
semaines
allez rencontrer des joueurs des jeunes
et des familles cetera sur le terrain on
va rappeler un vite vite on veut revoir
le tableau alors voyez les équipes club
de soccer dont parc extension
les comètes de brossard montréal nord
les griffons mont royal outremont les
griffons club de soccer également en
voilà 4 et puis repentignois
saint-eustache le dynamo las de
blainville et puis finalement club de
soccer de lyxor huit équipes qui qui
jouent des jeunes qui sont passionnés de
leur sport et vous en avez un passionné
avec vous je crois oui il s'appelle
patrice bernier vous le connaissez bien
le capitaine de l'impact de montréal
l'impact d'ailleurs les grands
partenaires avec notre défi coupe ma
coupe du monde et patrice qui est
également membre du jury qui va
déterminer le vainqueur de ce défi là
patrice d'abord merci d'être là et tu as
annonce une surprise aux jeunes
aujourd'hui c'est quoi oui bon
aujourd'hui on annoncé que l'impact de
montréal les invite tous à l'eau
prochain match à domicile 11 juin contre
ledit sionnel donc tous les jeunes sont
invités
et puis aurait une petite surprise pour
l'équipe gagnante des billets pour
seulement
oui des billets pour tout le monde donc
on va les attendre au stade où on espère
qu'il supporte et puis nous aider
grandement gagné un match à domicile
avec les vidéos et les tous que lily le
matériel que les jeunes vont nous
montrer sur les réseaux sociaux sur la
page web de radio-canada et on va voir
que beaucoup de talent au québec était
d'accord alex oui ben ce soit avec ça ça
va être beaucoup plus de jeunes en vue
pour voir le talent qui sont répartis à
travers le québec est surtout là ce soit
avec eux ces huit équipes qui font
partie du concours
mais oui beaucoup de talent beaucoup de
jeunes comme on l'a dit la lie aux 200
milles qui est jeune qui joue et puis ça
c'est seulement succès enregistrés et en
espérant qu'on peut bien localisé puis
on s'est joué en jeunes là bas un jour
ça ou plusieurs très gênants sont un
jour à l'époque de mon justement patrice
je me permets est-ce que iliad est ce
qu'on ressent l'effet de l'académie
parce qu'avant il y avait beaucoup
beaucoup de jeunes qui jouent à osaka
mais ils ne se rendaient pas à l'élite
nécessairement là est ce que il ya des
des jeunes dans la grande région de
montréal qui vont jouer un jour pour
l'impact
oui mais à plusieurs jeunes plus ils
maintenant l'académie le nepad au moins
jusque là on sent qu'il ya une structure
pour élever les jeunes sont aptes à
devenir des joueurs professionnels mais
aussi toute la structure amateur qui a
été là depuis des années qui leur permet
d'être en vue et puis il ya des cas de
détection est donc là on voit qu'il ya
une structure une pyramide beaucoup plus
structurée pour arriver au stade des
professionnels n'ont pas de l'avant
peut-être comme mon parcours ce que là
il y en avait un ou deux ou trois
quelques sons qui passait mais la honte
est qu'on va pouvoir dénicher beaucoup
plus l'espère mais merci beaucoup
patrice d'ailleurs j'en profite pour
rappeler à tout le monde que le prochain
match de l'impact à domicile c'est
samedi ce sera contre leur évolution de
la nouvelle angleterre je me suis pas
trop non c'est pas tout le monde nous
encourage et puis surtout on a besoin de
ce match au stade saputo merci beaucoup
patrice à vous merci je sais merci pour
tout aussi les jeunes qui on va donc se
revoir comme ça au toit des prochaines
semaines salut à tous